I created a ship it's gonna be Party
Central yup there's a jacuzzi is another
jacuzzi there's a fifth to 2z on this
thing please contribute to my
Kickstarter to make this a ten billion
dollar story so today we're talking
about prequels in the sci-fi genre
there's so many that it there have been
so many that are coming out like so low
ok prequels usually get a bad rap in the
sci-fi genre like there's some really
great ones but there's a lot of whiffs
it's tough man do we care about what
happened before the thing we care about
exactly a lot of the times they are sold
to us like there's gonna be a lot of new
discoveries and that's something for me
Thea's happens where it's like oh that
didn't happen no new discoveries in the
world of aliens because it's just people
running away from alien in the most
inefficient way to run away from things
they just run straight never sideways
running you literally just have to do
one of these when we talk about prequels
most people think of the Star Wars
prequels that were before this the
George Lucas trilogy which depending on
who you are is either unfairly maligned
or is not that great but I will put it
to you this way there was a great
trilogy that we just have it didn't get
the love it deserves Rise of the Planet
of the Apes War of the Planet of the
Apes the Planet of the Apes prequel
maybe better in certain ways than the
entire wealth of Planet of the Apes the
three is one of my favorite ones I think
oh I'm Jonathan I'm so different from
everybody sometimes I an contrarian for
contrarian sake
so it's kind of interesting because this
grouping like with rogue one and solo I
really kind of feel fills in the gaps of
after the prequels but before the events
of a new hope and then we have two other
trilogies that are being made off to the
side that we have no idea what they're
about might wanna buckle up baby
so Han and Lando recast obviously but
are there any other characters in Star
Wars Laura that could be recast as where
do you think it's a tall order I think
that if they had to recast Luke I think
Sebastian Stan aka the Winter Soldier
perfect another thing that would be
amazing is if I ended up in these movies
because I'm so insane about Chewie that
this is the thing that it should happen
the thing that happened and
well what do you know title character
that man that we all love so very much
han Solo I'm a driver flier waited a
long time for a shot like this a friend
of mine thought his name was hand
honestly if you listen to Han Solo one
of the things that they got right Han is
what Billy Dee Williams calls Han he
doesn't say Han and Donald Glover called
him han han old buddy there you go as
far as I'm concerned those two men can
do whatever they want and then Alden he
looks the part of Harrison Ford he
really does I feel like the guy might be
his little doppelganger and
the guy from age of Adaline is literally
his son reincarnated these also might be
the biggest shoes to fill of all time I
felt kind of bad for Chris Pine when he
had to beat Kirk in Star Trek I think he
did a good job and treats me know that
sort of recon that they did with Star
Trek is not talked about enough I heard
a story about you I was wondering if
it's true everything about me it's true
all right what can I say about Donald
Glover now forever to be known as the
young Lando Calrissian but once again
it's like enormous shoes to fill even
the Billy Dee was in the movies not that
long I wonder what his minute time
actually is I think when we talk about
the charisma I don't know if we've seen
anything from Alden that should kind of
show that we've seen plenty from Donald
Glover to show that I mean he's
literally a young Renaissance man he's
the like a cool antihero
and as long as they just keep those
things alive it's gonna be fine and he
teams up with Han I mean like that's
sort of dynamic between the two of them
the betrayal but also the friendship
it's kind of I think a thing they do it
a lot of these buddy movies that makes
it work space is lonely you have to have
good friends yes like Bruce Willis
hanging out with Milla Jovovich
Kirk and Spock is obvious the buddies
don't always have to be human I'm gonna
go robotic and say Stephanie and Johnny
v from short circuit they've had such a
good team all right so what's gonna
happen in solo
prepare yourself cuz Emilia Clarke's in
this movie
little rough around the edges good yeah
Newton and there will be wiki's that are
not chewy I'm super-pumped that Emilia
Clarke is in this because I think she
makes everything better yeah
other dragons obviously love she made a
terminator movie good you guys all I
will say is I don't know what exactly is
gonna happen but I do feel like this
one's gonna have the hi ste element Han
is a smuggler Woody Harrelson's seems to
be like The Fixer slash you know leader
of the group put him together he seems
like he's a mentor figure and he also
suspiciously talks like the Harrison
Ford version yeah of Han that we know
hey kid I'm putting together a crew and
I think in this movie we're gonna see
how Han gets the Millennium Falcon yeah
finally she's shiny and clean there's
some other great spaceships out there
besides the Millennium Falcon that I
think people like identify and love the
Nebuchadnezzar from matrix I always will
love that ship even though it's not as
clean what do you suppose the enterprise
was like when it was fresh off the
assembly line we saw it in Star Trek Zoe
Saldana playing Ahura was like screaming
Spock
be careful with the ship's box she's
brand new you know what scene I didn't
get was them eating off the floors I got
a really good feeling about
so I went ahead and created my own ship
all the Boston killer because news flash
I'm a bad guy there's gonna be party
central yo because there's a jacuzzi
there's another jacuzzi there's a fifth
jacuzzi on this thing and there's also a
small theater or something you know like
a 20 seat please contribute to my
Kickstarter to make this thing I am a
ten billion dollar story this is the
part of show redo trivia and today it's
sci-fi prequels alright up first when
was the first sci-fi film release 1907
Pee Dee what was an original
characteristic of Han Solo I'm going
with eye patch hey eye patch I like
imagining him with gills that's hot I'll
meet you underwater Han in the original
Star Wars trilogy how many non Jedi
wield lightsabers tricky tricky a 0 a 1
all right which is the fastest sci-fi
spacecraft all right
see TARDIS yeah that makes sense yes
yeah
Star Wars originally opened in how many
movie theaters in 1977 oh forget you
question stuff I'm choosing B I'm gonna
say C I'm gonna go with B here we go
which of these places does not share a
name with a character from the Alien
franchise it's a good one eh eh see
first now you're never to hear at the
end of it ever
so we have to chat about sci-fi prequels
up bunch loved it comment below we want
to look at them and respond and all that
stuff yep
and go get your tickets over at finding
go comm and on mobile see you next time
[Music]
you